all right welcome to 2022 people now if
the polls are right this year should be
one of great victories for the
republican populist movement now across
the country the grassroots is unified
behind policies that already make life
better for working americans of all
backgrounds
meanwhile their political opponents are
angry and divided
we all knew that senator manchin
couldn't be trusted the excuses that he
just made
i think are complete
the only thing we have to trust wolf
around here is our word and it's
unfortunate that it seems we can't trust
senator manchin's word
even aoc knows that the only way you can
have fun these days you have to leave
the mandate states and go to places like
sunny florida
but winning in november isn't going to
be enough
republicans need a governing agenda that
they can implement right out of the gate
we can't wait until 2024 in no way we
need members of congress who are ready
to govern now
and committee chairmen who will use
their oversight authority to keep the
biden administration in line
we need draft legislation that's what
i'm talking about that can fix the
broken policies still in place
now republican governors like ron
desantis are already showing what a
difference good government can actually
make
you look what's going on in other states
they're they're letting hysteria drive
them to doing really damaging things we
are a hundred percent committed to
making sure uh that people are able to
live their lives that our kids are able
to get an education uh that people's
businesses are able to to operate and
that people have jobs and so that is
just non-negotiable
and now it's time to take our movement
nationwide the angle platform includes
four major planks
first
saving our freedom
now both the federal and state
governments exceeded their
constitutional authority in myriad ways
they destroyed countless lives and the
name of public health
their extended use of emergency
authority without legislative approval
was and is an abomination and
anti-democratic
the consequences were devastating
now only now are the so-called experts
verbalizing the truth that we told you
21 months ago
there is the danger that there will be
so many people
who are being isolated who are
asymptomatic
for the full 10 days that you could have
a major negative impact
on our ability to keep society running
so the decision was made let's get that
cut in half and a cloth mask is not
going to protect you from a virus that
spreads through airborne transmission
don't wear a cloth mask cloth masks are
little more than facial decorations
we must never again allow government by
unaccountable experts no more lockdowns
no more school closures no more vaccine
mandates no more random testing mask
requirements all of it it all must end
when republicans take over
and you're not really free speaking of
freedom if you're terrified of walking
down the street
fighting crime we know it's mostly a
state responsibility but we need to put
the pressure on and keep it on
the gop needs to be the party of safe
streets
now we're tough on criminals because we
love our people our law-abiding
americans
so my question is does lori lightfoot
really love her city
certainly gangs and violent criminals
love her because they're literally
getting away with murder
chicago had its deadliest year in a
quarter century nearly 800 homicides
tragic
and being truly free also requires that
we resist any and all efforts to
undermine our system of free and fair
elections
democrats can never be allowed to pass
their bill to nationalize election laws
the gop has to say no to ballot
harvesting no to gutting voter id laws
and no to using covid as an excuse to
change the election rules
now the mail-in ballot push we knew this
was going to happen it's already begun
in new york and this has been their plan
all along
instead republicans have to make sure
that we return to the same common sense
principles that govern our elections for
decades
and we will know the results on election
night oh yes we will
and speaking of rule changes here's the
newest threat to our freedoms from
senate democrats trying to end the
filibuster
because if we don't change the rules the
republicans will block this and our
democracy could be at risk and even
wither in very real in real ways but
back in 2005 when republicans held the
majority in the senate schumer felt
another way
they want because they can't get their
way on every judge
to change the rules in midstream
to wash away 200 years of history they
want to make this country into a banana
republic it'll be a doomsday for
democracy if we do
a doomsday for democracy well his move
of course to end the filibuster now
smacks of pure desperation
he knows he doesn't have the votes the
old-fashioned way and that they're going
to get wiped out in november under the
old rules
so like the dictators he just referenced
in that old clip they do it across the
globe what do they do they change the
rules to keep themselves in power in
perpetuity
if democrats are able to pass this
so-called voting rights bill ensuring
one party ruled then shimmer is going to
be able to push through the left's
dangerous agenda no questions asked
now this brings me to my second plank
saving our independence that small thing
unlike the biden team we don't answer to
any type of international order the
united states is a free and independent
and sovereign country
we don't take orders from the eu or the
wto or the wh so or the um
our government and our military they
work for us
and speaking of our military we need to
propose
major reforms for the pentagon
their focus should be on confidence and
accountability now this requires
immediately ceasing biden's pentagon
obsession with diversity equity and
inclusion and the good old standby of
critical race theory
call me crazy but don't you want a
general who cares about winning battles
not spreading anti-american propaganda
the latest fad on the college campuses
now likewise we insist that our trade
negotiators walk away from bad deals and
we want a state department that fights
for our interests it doesn't just rub or
stamp whatever talking points it gets
from brussels
and by the way we shouldn't be
pretending that the murderous ccp
represents the chinese people
and this will help with our third plank
saving our economy
right now the u.s economy is being
carried by hard-working americans like
you
and you're seeing your wages stolen by
inflation
and you're facing onerous taxes and
endless regulations that make our lives
harder
this must stop
we will end all wasteful and unnecessary
spending and that goes for the
republicans
and we'll have trade and immigration
policies that give all working americans
a fair chance of success
and it'll prevent big business from
shipping jobs overseas
under this type of republican leadership
the border will once again be enforced
and those who came to abuse our system
and helped enrich the cartels they're
going to be sent home
and the angle's final plank is perhaps
the most important
saving our culture
the left has filled our media and our
public schools are universities with
anti-american hatred
left-wing mobs tear down our history
left-wing plutocrats ban american
critics from tech platforms we're going
to talk to dr malone coming up and of
course at the same time they coddle and
protect the ccp
meanwhile the democratic party thinks
that anyone who believes in traditional
notions of gender or sexual morality
they should be canceled or banned from
public life completely
this will not stand
the populist movement began over a
decade ago with the tea party
when they saw the damage done by federal
bailouts and obama's health care
takeover
and year after year we've urged
policymakers to trust the american
people to trust them with the truth to
respect their beliefs
and to give them a fair chance to
succeed through hard work
using you know those principles sticking
to those principles
we completely transformed the republican
party
we liberated it from the clutches of big
business and the war mongers and turned
into a vehicle for working people across
the country
every year and especially under trump
and his policies
we grew the base
and now we're becoming much more diverse
that is very good
every year states following our
principles gain more people and they
grow economically while left-wing states
are bleeding population and falling
behind
and today i hate to break the news to
oles cheney
but we're more united than ever while
the failures of the hard left
establishment she's now in bed with
grow more obvious by the day
so ours is a movement of optimism and of
hope
and it's time to take this movement
that includes our four planks laid out
tonight
to every corner of the country
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else